[Music]
hello gq my name is jonah hill and these
are my essentials
[Music]
my first essential
kiwi guava sparkling energy drink i
might just be like the biggest mark for
marketing of all time but it's like a
health food red bull so there's like
vitamins and they sell at like health
food stores but i think it's just like
really well marketed drink with a ton of
caffeine in it
and everyone thinks i own it because
whenever you work with me i like get
people hooked on celsius my greatest
achievement was this movie i did don't
look up by the end of the movie leo
jennifer lawrence
meryl streep and mark rylance were all
hooked on celsius so if y'all want to
send me a bunch of i don't own the
company or anything like that i just am
a fan i need to like wake up and do my
job i don't even drink coffee anymore i
call director juice
it's great
my next essential
is my little jonah directing starter
pack so
everywhere i
go on set i have my celsius
i have my turquoise american spirits
which is not a good one that i'm trying
to like recommend to people i should
quit as i'm 37 years old but i haven't
as of yet and i'm just keeping it real
with you guys
have you tried switching to vape kind of
i call them mouth fedoras has leo heard
you say mouth fedoras yes
i don't dis what anyone does to find
personal fulfillment so if you vape
respect but like i think of vapes as
mouth fedoras
the hydroflask is i don't drink enough
water so i
carry this with me and i try and drink
like two of them a day but i kind of
suck at it so it's mostly just like a
reminder of how much i suck
i love putting stickers on things this
is strong baby which is my production
company and i love all the peeps that
work there so shout out to the strong
baby productions crew and then i always
wear this bucket hat when i'm directing
i love it and then the most important
part is music so like one of the things
people don't do on sets is they don't
create like a vibe and so i was like
well when i direct and if i ever get to
direct movies i'm asking these people to
give like the hours of their life to
being here and i want them to be like i
had fun
i am always playing music out of this
this is the main event it's a bang
olufsen thing but it has the strap you
can be walking anywhere even like
hanging with the actors or talking to
the crew and you can bring
the vibe with you everywhere you go
another thing is smell like it really
smells bad most places you're shooting
so i really like this incense so i like
to bring it's called i don't know how to
pronounce the company
astier
de
villate
i ain't fancy so i don't know how to
pronounce it but i know how to smell it
it's good it like if there's music and
it smells good and you're kind of
laughing and dancing and like kind of
having fun even if you're making a
serious ass movie
i don't think people know this unless
you make movies like
it's straight-up porta-potties
everywhere at your job all the time when
i say it smells like [ __ ] like it
actually smells like [ __ ] at work after
like 15 years i was like maybe it'd be
cool if it didn't smell like
[ __ ] every day
my next one is this so this is a ring i
wear every day and it's a strong baby
ring
so my older sister dana she has a
company called the ten jewelry at
th e one zero jewelry
follow him on instagram family business
and she's so ill she can make you
anything so i just was like i want to
make a strong baby ring
and i kind of center the drawing and
this is what she came up with and she's
so sick and i wear it all the time love
her love love at the tan jewelry
i don't make any money off it by the way
[Music]
next essential item is stickers i always
have stickers with me i love stickers i
like to make stickers for things that
are even like inside jokes this is a
strong baby sticker which is like our
company obviously
and then surf juice california is an
inside joke my friends who got me into
surfing were spike jones and and mike
diamond from beastie boys but when i
started doing research on
surf culture in malibu there was a big
surf nazi culture it's almost like irony
poisoning you know kind of like 80s surf
culture but like basically all their
dads fought in world war ii against the
nazis so they were being punk and like
[ __ ] our parents so we're gonna be surf
nazis but then of course irony like
seeps into there's a great new york
times article that will explain a lot
better than me but i was obviously like
[ __ ] like all this classic malibu surf
imagery has like swastikas on it which
is so gnarly and [ __ ] up
so i was like yo we should start serve
jews so there's all this imagery of like
opposite of a swastika essentially it's
really fun and funny and silly and not
meant to be serious in the slightest so
i'm sure i'll get canceled for being
having a jewish star or yin yang or
something but like i don't know it's all
just to have a good time
[Applause]
[Music]
my next essential item so this is my
wetsuit for the summer
because it's
it's got the arms cut off which is great
tank top style my friends say i look
like like an old-timey boxer and this is
axe ax xxe this is a japanese company
and they're so sick they make my
favorite wetsuits i don't know how deep
you want to go into this but like
[ __ ]
[Music]
this is my next essential item mr zog's
coconut sex wax
it's awesome it smells really good i
love the way it smells
green's my favorite color so i gravitate
towards green things it's pretty iconic
and then it's also good and smells good
which is like
i like smell
hydrating argan oil mask this is a good
cutting move for
you guys at home anyone who like
bleaches their hair [ __ ] with their
hair a lot i bleach my hair a lot and
i'm in the ocean a lot so it gets all
like dark brown
like frizzy you know like christopher
lloyd in back to the future so you just
start in after you surf or take a shower
and then you leave it in and you're good
to go it smells good and it leaves you
feeling like silky smooth you know can
you like mime how you would apply it
no dude i'm not doing that
you do it
[Music]
okay now we're getting in the serious
stuff jiu jitsu
my man shooting this is a purple belt so
we got to give him some love over there
this is one of my favorite geese shout
out to bear from show your role show
your rules the [ __ ] i hit a point in my
life in my like early mid 30s where i
was like if i don't start like
developing hobbies and [ __ ] i'm gonna be
one of those people that only likes to
work and i can fall into the workaholic
category so i was like wouldn't it be
cool if the things i chose were things i
was really scared of my whole life so
the first one was jiu jitsu josh at
clockwork who's an amazing guy and then
also kenny florian who's an amazing guy
i was lucky enough to train with such
great people got me over that fear and
then that led to me breaking my fear of
surfing i think the hardest thing in the
world to do is to be present for me and
the two things i like to do
if you are not present you will
literally get [ __ ] up so like it
forces me to be present both things and
jiu jitsu definitely you will literally
get choked out if you're thinking about
like some [ __ ] you did two years ago
that you're bummed about you know
i learned early on if i roll in a class
everyone wants the story of i choked out
jonah hill i had to learn fast like it's
a story to basically beat the [ __ ] out
of me so i was like i'm also gonna pull
up in a peach gee
so like you know i'm just whatever dude
i'm not trying to be like a tough guy i
just am out here having fun and most of
the time i gotta say culturally people
have been really really [ __ ] cool
my last essential is my surfboard this
is what i'm currently riding shout out
to 88 surfboards i like riding foamies
i'm only two years into surfing whenever
i ride a foamy i go for more waves i
feel more like if i [ __ ] up or if
something bad happens i'm not gonna hurt
anyone or hurt myself what i love about
88 is you should watch their videos
their whole ethic is having fun they're
like serious aussie surfers that
grew up in all the harshness of surf
culture they can rip on anything but
they're like we just want to have fun
and ride foamies i just
like [ __ ] life is so serious like i
just want to try and have a good time
and smile
so this is my boy
mike d named it ron burgundy
so this is ron burgundy
thanks gq thanks for having me thanks
for everyone who watched this and i hope
this made you smile
[Music]